so today i'd like to take you on a
little journey with me and share my top
five harry potter gifts including one
that is the only one like it in the
entire world
and we're starting right now people of
the internet retro recontour here a
freshly
shaven retro-racking tour for the
christmas holidays merry christmas
happy holidays to all of you out there
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories
they tell we post videos every week here
on youtube and also
stream over on twitch so
by far my favorite harry potter themed
gift
is this one right here from a good
friend of mine
it is a custom made wand now you can't
see the wand yet obviously but first
you're seeing this custom-made box we'll
try and get some close-up shots for it
as well so you can get an idea of this
is this is
actual wood here green box uh and what i
love is he's got his last name is strong
so it says strong
wands here on the side he really did
go all out to put that little extra
touch on it
12 and 1 8 phoenix feather ash wand
and so here we go we're going to open it
up here let me let me try and get a good
view for you guys here so you can see
this
as we open it here the top just kind of
it doesn't really hold in place it just
slides off right there
and you see it's got this nice little
cloth down here
inside and then inside we have
the wand now of course you can buy ones
all over the internet i actually have
one that i got from the wizarding world
but this one is especially
significant to me because of the fact
that
he carved this himself guys i mean you
can kind of see
the detail here and this is held up i
mean this is a 10 plus year old
gift now at this point so it's held up
for quite some time
very smooth to the touch has a nice
little point on the end but not like too
sharp just i mean an incredible
gift and probably the the coolest thing
about it what i love more than anything
is at the bottom here we'll zoom in so
you can see this but
i am a huge playstation fan and at the
bottom he actually
carved in the playstation buttons so you
guys can see those
up close and personal uh the triangle
cross i call it x but you know sony
keeps referring to it as cross but
triangle
x circle and square so that is by far
my number one and will be very difficult
for anything to
ever surpass that just because of how
unique it is and guys i know
that you have some favorite harry potter
gifts so let me know
the coolest harry potter item you own
down in the comments below
i can't wait to hear what all you guys
have in store so as i mentioned in the
opening i've been a fan since
before the books even really blew up it
was a scholastic book order form
and don't judge a book by its cover this
was actually a book that i
judged by its cover i mean i was a kid
right i mean that's what we do
i was looking through the scholastic
book order and that
cover of sorcerer's stone just
immediately
caught my eye then i read the little
description i was like i have to get
this
checked it out for my library and at the
time chamber of secrets of prisoner of
azkaban hadn't even
came out in the u.s yet so that's how
far back we were talking i was very
early
on this bandwagon for harry potter and
one of the first gifts i think it was at
the same
book fair where i ended up buying
prisoner basketband and chamber of
secrets when they came out
but at that book fair i got this little
harry potter bookmark
and it is there's nothing special about
it i mean if you
if it's one of those bookmarks that if
you turn like this
you uh it changes scenes so you've got
gryffindor and then harry putting on the
sorting hat
and it's all scratched up it's it's bent
it's
it's got marks all over the back but
it's just the significance of
how long ago i got this and the fact
that
it was my bookmark reading all seven
books which is
truly incredible i i guess technically
six books because the first one i didn't
have it yet but my favorite part is the
little tassel here it's it's a little
sorting hat
tassel we'll get a close-up shot for you
on that as well but this little tassel
right here
is is by far the coolest part that makes
it stand out
and okay this is kind of two items in
one really three items in one but also
these bookends
that these were some of the first gifts
that i ever received when i first
started reading the books
my mom got me these bookends i have no
idea where she even got them from but
harry and hermione you see harry's has
quidditch on it and hermione says magic
on the
side as you're looking at this video
here
you might be able to see where they have
been broken
so many times when i was a kid my sister
knocked off hermione's hand the hand
that's holding the lawn she actually
knocked off
so i super glued that back on then i got
him out as an
adult and one day my two-year-old son
was up there
he knocked off hermione's one the one
just like snapped right off
and then harry's glasses so all this
it's been super glued multiple times
but again it's the nostalgia there it's
what they mean to me
and that's really why i love them so
much so i'm keeping them around
hopefully they can last a little bit
longer for me my next one
is one that was widely available but i
have no idea how many copies of these
things they made this was the
collector's edition of beetle the bard
they sold these on
amazon and i don't even know if they
sold them anywhere else
but it was actually for charity it was
something that jkr did for charity
and there was a chance that some of them
would be autographed
so you think it's this big huge book uh
this is really just
a case for the book so once you kind of
open it up here
see if we can get see if we can get it
open after all these years
so it opens up like this right here and
then the book itself comes in this
really nice little bag right here
and you open up the bag and then it is
an actual copy
of beetle the bard but it is a
custom version a special version of
beetle the bard it does not look like
the regular version that you can buy in
stores everywhere it's got this little
clasp here on the side
so i'm going to go ahead and open that
up right there and i've actually never
read
with with this specific book i've read
beetle the bard
but i haven't read this copy because i
just i really want to keep it preserved
and so that is the book but in addition
to the book
it also came with full-sized
versions of the artwork so here there's
a little sleeve here on the
on the left side right here children's
high level group i'm glad they put this
in here that is the charity that this
uh went to because it was like i want to
say it was like over 100
or something the book itself but this
artwork in here
is really awesome and i'm almost
positive that
jkr did this artwork herself
pay me the treasure of your past this
one right here
uh the next one the fountain of fair
fortune
i haven't read these in forever man i'd
love to reread these
they're very short beetle barred very
quick read of course everybody remembers
the tale of the three brothers because
that's the one that plays so prominently
into deathly hallows but i remember
enjoying all of them here there's
another
another artwork right there wizard and
the hopping pot i think it was called
testing my knowledge here i'm not gonna
fact check this until later i'll let you
guys fact check me on it
warlock's hairy heart warlocks some
something about a heart
that's all i can remember something to
do with the heart not telltale heart no
so not your average
collector's edition by the way for my
hogwarts legacy fans out there i'm
thinking one of my next videos is gonna
be
what would you like to see in a hogwarts
legacy
collector's edition because
this right here to me like this is a
top-notch
collector edition special edition item
whatever you want to call it
so many of the games these days they
just include things that
frankly i don't really care about so
hopefully hogwarts legacy i hope they're
planning a collector's edition they may
not even be planning one but i think
it'd be awesome if they
did my next gift i meant to bring home
with me but is actually in my office at
work
and it is a golden snitch that is a
clock
my wife got me this for a birthday years
ago
it's actually more recent this one was
just a few years ago
and i love that i can display it at work
but it's actually a
really nice like it's very well made if
you've ever seen this thing before or
you've seen it online and thought about
getting it
i have to say it is incredibly well made
i love mine i just need to get some new
batteries for it right now
the fifth item is my
gryffindor hoodie this is uh the one
that is sold
at the wizarding world of harry potter
in orlando this is from my first trip
there so you know what let's go and put
it on by far what i love about the most
is how it says
gryffindor down the side here i think
that's pretty cool then you got the line
up here
zip up always love the zip up does have
the hood on it as well what i want
let me check this out in the hood it's
got a little design in here and then
just
red on top also has the little pockets
down at the bottom because my hands
constantly free so very nice that it has
that this was from my very first trip
and
right now only trip to the wizarding
world of harry potter i went shortly
after it opened
and i actually haven't been able to go
back since they opened gringotts and all
that so i'm really anxious to get back
down there
hopefully once all the whole pandemic
thing goes away i'll be able to get back
down to orlando and check it out because
i've heard it's pretty
pretty cool as always guys thank you so
much for watching
this year has been an incredible year
for me i thank you all so much for all
the support you've shown the channel
i wish you a very merry christmas and a
happy new year thank you all so much
i'll see you in 2021